uh Matthew told me that he is uh hard at
work on a number of things but you know
Kingsman is a part of it yeah so have
you spoken to him about another one is
it yeah
um yeah I mean I don't know what I
should say really uh
be careful with what you say but tell me
what you can yeah I mean I
so you know I so
I haven't I have an idea for Kingsman I
haven't I have my own idea that I would
like to pitch to Matthew
um and I think that will be happening
soon but he has a he has he has the
wheels in motion on a big idea of his
own
um so who knows you know who knows where
it will land but he has every intention
of making it oh and and I have every
intention of playing actually
one more time that was always what I
thought I was committed to doing
um
I just it's the it's the role that it's
the role that made my name so
I suppose in a way
I just want it to be absolutely right
if we do it again and I want the story
to be I want the story to to do to do
justice to to the part that really
changed my life
um and I I wanted to be a fitting ending
so
um
and I would obviously really hope that
Colin would would come back for at least
a part of it and um who knows we'll have
to see you know but we are planning to
talk about it actually the next time we
see one another so who knows watch this
space but you know he's certainly not um
he's certainly not backing off the idea